bomb craters destruction and the
obliterated remains of people's lives
the closer you get to the new Eastern
Front the more dead Russian soldiers you
find
[Music]
the volleys of shells and Rockets crash
back and forth
foreign
s of Russian soldiers litter the road
from where they were dug in just a
couple of days ago the Ukrainian Army
now shelled them in the town of criminal
where they fled
it's been terrible there's been no life
our neighbors left and the Russian
soldiers took over their houses but when
they left they were running panicking on
the street
Russian military uniforms in abandoned
homes the soldiers commandeered now
empty by the detritus they left behind
the surrounding forests have been
pulverized by exploding shells tanks
apcs and all manner of burnt out
Vehicles line the road
Ukrainian rocket launchers moved to
positions ahead
we were sitting in our basement for
three to four days just arriving there
was so much shelling and then they fled
into the forests
we crossed the partly destroyed Bridge
which is near collapse
the smashed school bus is empty bar two
dead Russian soldiers hanging at its
sides
[Music]
the buzz of swarming flies is the only
Sound by the terrifying explosions of
battle
an elderly woman appears at her gate she
describes the Russian and the tree
they were moving everywhere driving on
the road lots of vehicles but I'm afraid
to speak about it she says
foreign
she doesn't even Flinch when a shell
explodes close by
when the Russians gave us humanitarian
Aid she continues there were about 700
of us but many left for the Russian side
just before the Ukrainian Army liberated
The Village
we slowly move up the road careful to
avoid the unexploded bombs and shrapnel
that has ripped through more vehicles
and bodies on the hill
barrage of incoming shells Land close by
there's been intense shelling here in
the last few minutes as a few soldiers
behind me that are running towards this
Village after Village has been
completely destroyed in this area as
Ukrainian forces push forward along this
road towards the town of cremina
hear a drone overhead go go go go now if
you don't want your cars destroyed shout
the terrified Ukrainian soldiers as they
run by
Charles Stratford Al Jazeera torsky
eastern Ukraine